[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue non pas sur le plateau
de la terre des dates à dire mais chez
moi confinement oblige nous allons nous
intéresser dans cette émission deux pays
cités en exemple pour leur gestion de
l'épidémie
l'allemagne et le maroc je vais recevoir
par skype
edouard husson qui est historien
spécialiste de l'allemagne et rachid h
achi qui lui est économiste chercheur en
sciences sociales et qi qui parlera de
casablanca où il réside alors commençons
tout de suite par l'allemagne
edouard husson bonjour vous êtes jeune
historien professeur à l'institut franco
allemand d'études européennes à
l'université cergy pontoise
vous êtes auteur de paris berlin la
survie de l'europe qui est paru en
novembre dernier aux éditions gallimard
alors l'allemagne est citée en exemple
pour sa gestion du grenat virus il se
trouve que c'est un pays plus peuplés
que la france où le nombre de contaminés
semble sensiblement le même
et où il ya en revanche eu quatre fois
moins de morts que dans le nôtre pays
alors d'abord est ce qu'on est sûr que
les allemands comptabilise bien tous les
décès à l'hôpital dans les ehpad et à
domicile oui écoutez là je ne sais qu'il
ya eu des questions au départ parce
qu'il semblait étonnant que le nombre de
morts allemands soient actuellement
quatre fois inférieur au nombre de
français pour un nombre de personnes
contaminées et piette qui est
sensiblement le même
en tout cas selon selon les chiffres
donnés par les deux pays
alors il faut par ailleurs qui a sans
doute moins de personnes contaminées en
allemagne parce que l'allemagne est plus
et elle recense plus des gens contaminés
alors qu'en france on teste peut on a
déplu bateaux de pêche au monde et donc
incapable de dire si nous nous avons
calé notre taux de mortalité réel
probable qu'il soit plus proche du taux
allemand si on si on avait fait autant
de tests que l'allemagne puisque je vous
rappelle que l'allemagne fait 350 mille
tests un peu par semaine c'est le
l'objectif fixé par le ministère de la
santé est un objectif de 500 mille tests
par semaine on peut penser que les
allemands le l'atteindront dans quelques
semaines
alors on peut dire que l'allemagne
n'avait pas de masque elle non plus un
grosse pénurie de masques au début de
nos début de l'épidémie et que le
gouvernement a plutôt minimisé la
dangerosité du record navires us à la
fin du mois de janvier on parlait encore
en allemagne de risque sanitaire faible
saft et 22 janvier le 27 janvier le
gouvernement considérait que la
probabilité de propagation de la maladie
était très faible et le candide 19
étaient grosso modo considéré comme
plutôt moins dangereux qu'elle veille
saisonnière
oui alors écoutez je crois que d'abord
effectivement il faut faire attention à
ne pas faire des reproches injustes à
tel ou tel pays qui a mal anticipé ou
vérité c'est que on a on a un phénomène
assez classique dans tous les pays
occidentaux et a fortiori dans l'union
européenne
les services de renseignement
avertissent dès le mois de décembre
qu'il se passe quelque chose en pin qui
n'est pas normal
en termes l'épidémie mais vous savez
c'est pas parce qu'un service a envoyé
une note que cette note elle se retrouve
sur le bureau de la chancelière ou du
président de la république en france du
président américain
on s'est très vite ce sont des des
processus bureaucratique donc on a
sous-estimation par la grande bretagne
l'allemagne la france les états unis de
l'étendue de l'épidémie
et surtout on ne connaît pas la nature
du coronavirus à cette époque donc une
fois qu'on est pas tout le monde est
sûre si j'ose dire sur la même ligne de
départ
la question c'est de comprendre pourquoi
l'allemagne réagit mieux réagi plus vite
s'adaptent mieux et c'est là qu'on va
trouver des différences non pas dans la
capacité d'anticipation dans la capacité
d'adaptation
à une situation de crise alors on a
tendance à dire en france que les
allemands sont plus disciplinés que
l'ouvrier j'aime et j'ai du mal à
prononcer le mot tellement il ne me
semble étrange et alors est ce que c'est
le cas d'abord il me semble que les gds
allemande a organisé jusqu'au bout des
fêtes décor n'a fait comme il le disait
qu'on allait dans les parcs et que
pendant le même pendant les mesures de
confinement plus souple qu'en france on
continue de se rendre en forêt par
exemple oui effectivement là la mauvaise
blague des jeunes allemands s'étaient de
s'acheter par paquets entiers de la
bière corona et de l'attenté du camp
navires us si j'ose dire
donc c'était effectivement de très
mauvais goût et c'était surtout un très
en deçà de ce qui allait se passer
donc si vous voulez je pense qu'il faut
il faut sortir des clichés sur le la
discipline d'hôtel peuple ou le
l'anarchisme de tel autre
on a on a effectivement un rapport à la
loi qui est différent selon selon les
sociétés
enfin vous savez je vais simplement vous
donner un exemple qui nous fait sortir
de notre sujet mais le rapport des
allemands à la loi si vous êtes sur
l'autoroute
lorsqu'il de gauche permet la vitesse
illimitée et que vous ne vous rabattez
pas sur la file de droite et bien la
voiture le bolide qui arrive derrière
vous il va vous doublez pour droite
donc si vous voulez le rapport des
allemands à la loi ça voudrait bien ça
voudrait bien une thèse c'est plus
compliqué que ce qu'on le croit donc
pour revenir à ce sujet non il est
certain si vous voulez que la force du
système allemand c'est la
décentralisation de la lutte contre
l'épidémie il y a dans le système
allemand dé des agences locales de santé
publique qui sont niveau 1 régional et
ce sont elles qui sont au premier rang 1
coordination des moyens
ensuite vous avez niveau au dessus des
ministères fédéraux pardon des miss et
régionaux l'émissaire régionaux et puis
vous avez enfin ministère fédéral
mais à chaque niveau on sait ce qu'on
doit faire et les ministères régionaux
effectivement ce qui a caractérisé la
réaction de la bavière du bade
wurtemberg et de la rhénanie du nord
westphalie les trois länder les plus
touchées dès le moins brillé par
l'épidémie
c'est qu'ils se sont coordonnés et puis
à partir de la fin février du début mars
c'est là le gouvernement fédéral entre
dans le jeu et de manière à coordonner
sur des aspects plus stratégique mais si
vous voulez plutôt les aspects de
soutien économique aux entreprises
plutôt la vision de fermer la frontière
qui ne pouvait être prise que qu'au
niveau du gouvernement fédéral donc
chacun sait ce qu'il fait à chaque
niveau et le niveau de la lutte contre
l'épidémie
ce sont les ce sont les agences locales
des publics la décentralisation ça peut
être un inconvénient aussi on pourrait
imaginer que les lander les plus pauvres
vont subir de plein fouet l'épidémie
tandis que les plus riches vont mieux se
protéger ou pour imaginer que
l'allemagne applique à l'intérieur de
son pays
ce qu'elle applique un peu à l'europe
c'est à dire en gros il n'y a pas de
raison que les riches payent pour les
pour les pauvres
est ce que c'est le cas est ce qu a eue
est ce qu'il ya eu des différences comme
ça entre les länder vous mettez d'oise
sur sur les sons elle est sûre la streak
il y a entre ce qu'on pourrait appeler
la fédération européenne et la
fédération la république fédérale
d'allemagne
c'est que entre länder de république
fédérale d'allemagne
les rich effet pu des transferts vers
les länder les plus pauvres il ya un
sentiment national allemand il n'y a pas
de sentiment européens tels que
l'allemagne soit prêt à payer pour les
thérapies et en particulier pour
l'italie du nord on y reviendra tout
l'or il a fallu là la pression de
l'industrie allemande de l'industrie
automobile allemande pour que la
chancelière merkel se sentent obligés de
s'impliquer plus dans la dans le soutien
européen
parce que l'industrie automobile
allemande a dit
deux sont sous traitement c'est eux qui
on est on est atteint de plein fouet
bon donc donc si vous voulez là il ya
une différence énorme et bavaroise
solidaire avec un son ou un mec clan
bourgeois beaucoup plus que 1 allemand
de se sent solidaire avec un espagnol ou
un grec alors une des grandes
différences entre l'allemagne et la
france c'est qu'il y avait beaucoup de
tests 1 il avait beaucoup plus de tests
toute personne présentant des symptômes
même bénin a été testée semble-t-il
gratuitement à la fois dans les hôpitaux
dans les cabinets médicaux mais aussi on
l'a vu sur les parkings oui bien sûr
l'allemagne si vous voulez pas d'emblée
deux mesures préventives ou quasiment
d'emblée de mesures préventives la
fermeture des frontières et les tests
actifs
ce sont des mesures de bon sens ce sont
des mesures qui n'étaient pas rares pour
le coup c'était pas contre les voisins
européens
mais à partir du moment où l'autriche
est très contaminée la france est très
contaminée ils étaient tous temps normal
que l'allemagne songe à fermer ses
frontières et d'autre part
l'allemagne a aussi fait exactement
comme la corée est lapidé doter
rapidement et beaucoup de manière à
avoir une idée de qui est véritablement
infectés et de fait ces sacs qui a aidé
à ce que on n'aille pas sur un
confinement total mais qu'on est plutôt
une mise en place de distance vocation
sociale renforcée
alors pour faire des tests qu'il fallait
être capable d'en fabriquer l'allemagne
où le sait très puissante industrie
pharmaceutique mais la france aussi
pourquoi est ce que l'allemagne a pu
fabriquer des tests et pas nous mais
vous savez avant de fabriquer des tests
l'allemagne en a acheté est ce que il ya
quelque chose que qu'on ne veut pas voir
en france c'est que dès la fin février
début mars
vous n'aviez par exemple des entreprises
coréennes qui avait fabriqué plus de
tests quand elle en avait besoin qu'ils
proposaient leurs services aux
différents pays européens
ces mêmes entreprises ont été en contact
immédiat
avec les ministres régionaux santé en
allemagne et attendent toujours la
réponse du ministère central de la santé
en france ou drs donc qui voulait être
une différence et d'adaptation de
réaction à la crise ensuite il est bien
vrai que l'allemagne est un pays qui est
resté plus industrialisés que la france
deux fois plus industrialisés et que
pour cette raison là effectivement
l'allemagne a gardé beaucoup plus que
nous une mentalité industrielle donc la
capacité à penser les investissements de
long terme donc la capacité à mettre en
place une gestion de crise et donc aussi
la capacité à reconvertir les sites de
production par exemple les sites
industriels bade wurtemberg ce sera
fabriqué des respirateurs des
ventilateurs
qu'en est il du budget de la santé en
allemagne on accuse beaucoup les
gouvernements qui se sont succédés en
france d'avoir réduit les budgets des
hôpitaux publics alors qu'en est-il en
allemagne et qu'en est il du du budget
de la recherche aussi on dit que cumuler
le budget de la recherche publique et de
la recherche privée il atteindrait 90
milliards d'euros en allemagne pour
seulement 7 milliards et écouter de deux
choses d'abord le le budget de la santé
est à peu près le même dans les deux
pays
doublement en cela par la part de
l'administration hospitalière et le
ministre à sion de la santé français 2
et 2 et 2 occupe à peu près un tiers du
budget concerné alors que en allemagne
c'est en 20 % donc vous avez quelque
chose qui est évident c'est que
l'allemagne a dépensé mais pas pour la
technostructure système de santé et pour
un système centralisé dirigé depuis la
capitale elle a investi dans les
hôpitaux
et elle a mis en place une une techno
très légère pour la gouvernance du
système
donc effectivement l'allemagne était
capable de dégager d'emblée
28 lits de réanimation quand la france
en avait que cinq mille à disposition au
départ alors sur la recherche
ce projet ne sais pas si le la cherche
moi je pense et sans vouloir entrer
absolument dans un débat franco français
je pense que le lac et c'est beaucoup
plus de médecine et là vous avez un
autre phénomène qui se passe en france
nous avons une difficulté de l'hôpital
public à coopérer avec pital privé
nous avons eu des malentendus entre les
un médecin de ville comme on dit les
médecins généralistes et les autorités
françaises
alors qu'en allemagne il n'y a pas du
tout ce système comme tout est géré de
manière décentralisée le privé le public
les médecins généralistes les médecins
hospitaliers les agences de santé se
sont parlé on coquet de manière tout à
fait naturelle
on dit néanmoins que plus de médecins en
allemagne qu'en france 4 3 pour mille en
allemagne 3 4 pour mille ans en france
cela n'a pas joué
pour vous c'est vraiment une preuve un
problème de de bureaucratie qui serait
plus importante en france qu'en
allemagne
je pense que c'est un équipage crédit à
la bureaucratie parce que l'allemagne
est capable d'être très bureaucratique
elle aussi quand elle le veut mais le
fait que les décisions et pu être prise
au plus près du terrain
c'est le comme je le disais tout à
l'heure les agences locales de santé
publique elle son niveau infra
régionales elle coordonne les les
interventions hospitalière en cadets en
cas de pandémie a au niveau de plusieurs
villes à l'intérieur d'un lente donc ça
ça a été extrêmement important et ce qui
fait qu'il ya on a on appuie t de perdre
tant on a perdu en france avec des
allers-retours permanents entre entre
paris entre paris et les régions
ça c'est à mon avis la différence
fondamentale
le différentiel du nombre de médecins ne
me semble pas avoir un obstacle absolu
du côté français en revanche la la
les mictions permanente du pouvoir
central dans le poindre processus vous
donner un autre exemple qui n'est pas
liée là directement à la médecine mais
qui est liée à l'état de confinement là
au niveau fédéral on a fixé un état
minimal du confinement
c'est c'est ce seul confinement que
l'allemagne a mis en place depuis depuis
le 15 mars à peu près en certains länder
ont comme la bavière ont décidé d'avoir
un confinement plus plus fort mais on
les a laissés faire c'était de leur
responsabilité et est ce qui a permis
d'avoir un confinement différencier
correspondant à l'état de gravité de la
pandémie selon on a ça en france on a
des maires qui ont trouvé qu'il fallait
limiter les sorties on n'avait pas le
droit de sortir en plus de 10 mètres de
son domicile
on a laissé comme ça une petite
l'attitude aussi à toutes les fantaisies
si l'on peut dire oui sauf qu'il ya
cette mère qui se sont vu interdire de
prendre des de prendre des règlements
spécifiques le pouvoir central c'est en
est quand même mais lewin quand ça
devenait trop délirant être
culturellement vous pensez que il ya des
attitudes allemande qui explique
justement cette plus grande efficacité
cette meilleure adaptation cette plus
grande rapidité
après tout on l'a souvent vu à l'oeuvre
y compris lors des deux dernières
guerres mondiales
ouais enfin écrit il les empêche donc
les ont perdus mais on a cru qu'il
allait gagner
voilà donc si vous voulez je pense que
là on entre dans sa balle à débat plus
complexe si on ceci on se concentre sur
la sur le corps navires us si vous
voulez je crois que l'on voit on voit
très clairement deux facteurs de
l'efficacité de la décentralisation et
d'autre part la mutalité industriels il
faudrait en ajouter un troisième qui est
le bon usage que l'allemagne fait de la
révolution numérique de la pression
digitale
parce que on parlait tout à l'heure de
coordination en france la lutte contre
l'épidémie
on a continué à la pensée comme le
rapport entre paris et le local est ce
tellement alors les graisses se
comportant finalement comme des relais 2
de skins vous voulez à paris en
allemagne vous avez eu l'émergence de
beaucoup de choses vous avez eu par
exemple une une plateforme qui a permis
de mettre en lien là les les différents
les différents hôpitaux qui avait besoin
de coopérer quand il y avait un manque
de masques
ici un manque de tests là quand il
manque les liens andrault il y avait des
choses extrêmement simple grâce à une
plateforme numérique
vous avez aussi des entreprises qui ont
mis en place des ac at on pour des
initiatives de la meilleure initiative
par exemple pour faire les courses pour
pour les personnes âgées condamner à
l'isolément et donc vous avez eu comme
ça d'une culture une vraie culture des
start up de l'innovation pas simplement
des slogans sur la start up née schott
mais vous avez eu quelque chose de faits
réels tissu de la société civile qui a
été encouragé par les länder près par
l'état et qui a permis aux allemands de
s'organiser extrêmement vite pour pour
effectivement au plan local
imaginer des solutions en ce moment en
france il ya plein de thunes où le débat
sur le traçage des données téléphoniques
rien talent en allemagne y'a pas un
débat de la même ampleur parce que le
gouvernement ne l'a pas proposé
s'il y avait un si si ça doit être
proposée y aurait le même débat en
france mais si vous voulez je vais vous
prendre un autre exemple comparer la la
corée et taïwan
vous verrez que time man a fait montre à
sage est beaucoup plus est encore que
l'accord donc je pense que le la
solution la solution allemande et qui
n'est pas libé seed 1 c'est celle du
nombre de tests essai de l'objectif dès
le départ d'assurer
zone test est donc ça n'a pas rendu ça
ne rend pas nécessaire question du la
question du king alors l'allemagne a
commencé à des confiné depuis le 20
avril les écoles réouvre on parle de
rendre les masques obligatoire à partir
du 27 avril
néanmoins il y a une grande peur d'un
rebond d'une deuxième vague
oui effectivement mais je dirais que
tout ça se passe de manière de manière
posée poser rationnelle je pense que le
l'inquiétude allemande porte beaucoup
plus sur l'étendue de la récession
économique qui va suivre
mais pour rester sur le déconfinement la
discussion est menée tout à fait
rationnellement et tous les comme nous
n'avions eu ce me confine à la sortie la
sortie du du semis confinement s'éteint
c'est un semi déconfinement donc ça n'a
pas le caractère matic un lieu à énorme
et de vidéos humoristiques pour savoir
comment les femmes vont faire chez le
coiffeur
effectivement et quelle quelle va être
la taille des ciseaux utilisés ou
comment comment on va pouvoir se mettre
sous le masque être être prêt à distance
bon mais voilà c'est fait sur un mode
bon enfant dans les magasins il ya
certains magasins vous n'êtes pas
accepter si vous ne portez pas de masque
enfin voiliers sont des choses qui sont
qui sont négociés localement je quitte
l'allemagne est beaucoup plus inquiètes
sur autre chose qui est là la récession
par exemple l'industrie automobile
profite certes des ailes débloqués par
l'état
mais la question c'est très partiel des
sites de production en europe centrale
c'est l'arrêt quasi complet des du
travail chez les sous traitants
on y deux pays du nord c'est la question
de savoir à quelle vitesse la chine va
se remettre à acheter des véhicules
allemands et là je crois que c'est le
gros de l'inquiétude dans la société
allemande
on sait qu'en des mâles la merkel est
une scientifique au départ alors est-ce
que ça a joué
allemagne et est ce qu'il y à autant de
médecins en allemagne à la télévision
qu'il y en a chez nous aujourd'hui
alors écoutez moi je je suis extrêmement
sceptique sur le rôle que l'on veut
faire jouer angela merkel dans cette
crise ou gives a deux aspects positifs
le fait qu'elle soit scientifique fait
qu'elle évite les envolées lyriques et
les grands discours et le fait qu'elle
soit finalement une chancelière plutôt
affaibli politiquement dans un état très
décentralisée et très fédéral fait qu'
elle n'a pas grand chose à faire et donc
ça évitera les ratés il ya eu en longe
l'ordre du nucléaire en 2015 sur sur
l'immigration non je crois que si vous
voulez angela merkel ne joue aucun rôle
sinon d'avoir retrouvé sa figure
maternelle protectrice mais ceux qui
agissent ian weinstein le le ministre
fédérale de la santé qui lui
effectivement est et allah est à la
manoeuvre et d'autre part les ministres
présidents des länder en particulier des
trois länder de rhénanie du nord de
pittsburgh et de bavière qui sont
extrêmement actifs qui sont vraiment en
première ligne en tweets
oui il ya déjà des médecins à la
télévision allemande
mais d'abord vous savez que bon la
les régionales essentiellement dans sa
structure la télévision publique
au delà des par ailleurs des chaînes
privées donc les débats sont souvent
menées au niveau région et par ailleurs
il n'y a pas assez
ces guerres idéologiques c'est que vous
voulez comme il y en a par exemple
autour du traitement de proposer de la
thérapie proposée par guy raul tant
franc passait hier de principe
le débat est mené beaucoup plus
calmement alors est ce que est ce qu'il
faut que la france entretiennent une
fois de plus son complexe d'infériorité
à vis de l'allemagne devant les bons
chiffres de l'allemagne
est-ce que là encore la fille la france
va devoir faire c'est son mea culpa
d'après vous les doigts usant écoutez je
pense que là on a toujours le même
problème en france qu' on parle d'un
modèle allemand mais on ne regarde pas
où se situe ce qu'il y a de vraiment
exemplaire en allemagne ce que ce que
l'on a vu effectivement c'est que du
point de vue opérationnel
du point de vue de l'action du point de
vue pas citer d'organisation et
coordination au niveau local et au
niveau régional
l'allemagne est tout à fait un pays
exemplaire en revanche et c'est l'être
c'est de ça qu'il faudrait s'inspirer
il faudrait qu'on laisse prospérer les
initiatives locales envie de faire
niveau local régional en france plutôt
que de vouloir réglementer tout en
permanence fin penser qu'il faut un
décret autorisant les pharmaciens à
vendre des masques anti su raconter ça
un allemand il va vous regarder avec des
yeux exorbités
en revanche on regarde absolument vers
la chanson est vers la politique p n de
l'allemagne qui elle aussi ne change pas
qui est une politique sans vision les
allemands si vous voulez le débat états
du nord contre états du sud en europe
il est assez ridicule en ce moment la
région la plus touchée en europe c'est
l'italie du nord qui est l'une des
régions économiques les plus
performantes d'europe donc que l'on ne
vienne pas nous expliquer à à berlin que
c'est le résultat de la mauvaise gestion
de l'europe du sud
c'est c'est le piémont et la lombardie
deux des berceaux l'économie européenne
depuis le moyen-âge qui sont en grande
difficulté et on a du mal à comprendre
de ce point de vue là l'absence de
vision stratégique à berlin est et donc
au niveau européen donc vous voulez pour
moi il n'ya pas de modèle il ya le fait
que l'allemagne est exemplaire pour ce
qu'elle sait faire elle est restée une
nation à la mentalité industriels et ça
il faut réfléchir là dessus
en revanche a toujours aussi peu de
leadership stratégique cas qu'il ya dix
ans
lors de la financière a non plus ça n'a
pas changé merci edouard husson
on va maintenant se tourner vers un
autre pays cités en exemple c'est le
maroc
je vais appeler à china shanxi
à casablanca mais aussi edouard ils
seront portez vous bien
merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]
nous voilà de retour avec rafi d'achat
fille qui est économiste chercheur en
ensemble en sciences sociales
rachid de vous êtes marocains vous
résidez à casablanca vous est également
chroniqueur sur luxe radio
le maroc est devenu un exemple dans la
gestion de la pandémie de gros navires
us c'est le troisième le pays le plus
touché du continent africain mais en
proportion du nombre de cas confirmés il
y a trois fois moins de morts que qu'en
france alors à priori comment
l'expliquez vous moi déjà faut rappeler
que le maroc est l'un des pays les mieux
intégrés à l'économie mondiale dans la
région notamment avec des partenaires
comme la france l'italie l'espagne et
qui sont les pays les plus touchés par
la pandémie est donc naturellement les
premiers cas importés au maroc étaient
des cas venant d'italie d'espagne et de
france
donc soit des marocains qui étaient là
pour tourisme pour des raisons
professionnelles fois d'aimer re des
marocains résidant à l'étranger qui
venait rendre visite à leurs proches
et donc on a eu un petit à petit le
passage de 40 portés à des foyers
communautaires locaux donc des marocains
qui contamine d'autres marocains mais il
faut comprendre que l'efficacité dont on
parle n'est pas un choix en réalité
c'est un impératif pour différentes
raisons la première c'est les moyens
limités dont dispose le maroc en termes
de gestion sanitaire en termes de
l'hydre animations en termes de nombre
de médecins par habitant
donc on est à sept points trois médecins
pour 10000 habitants à comparer par
exemple avec la france on est à 34 ou au
now cuba où en est à 75 pour les lits de
réanimation paraît on est à un peu plus
de 1610 de réanimation ce qui est
largement inférieur à ce qu'ils
réclamaient donc on n'a pas le droit on
n'a pas le luxe de fait permettre de mal
gérer l'épidémie est donc dès le départ
ce qui a été adoptée c'est un principe
de précaution est donc au lieu
d'attendre que la phase 1 2 3 arrive en
prendre des mesures drastiques dans
l'immédiat dont les décliner
graduellement en vue de les faire
accepter par la population et on gagne
du temps en vue de se doter des moyens
de logistique en vue de gérer par la
suite l'épidémie est donc tout est venu
graduellement mais dans une logique bien
réfléchi et le maroc a également
redécouvert un certain nombre de cas ce
que là on parle d'un changement de
paradigme
l'idée c'est qu'il ya quelques mois tout
le monde vanter les mérites du libre
échange et de la mondialisation elle a
aujourd'hui quasiment tout le monde
devient souverainiste protectionnistes
donc ça c'est intéressant de voir que le
réalisme a primé sur le discours
idéologique pour après on pourra aborder
les différents aspects à l'origine de ce
réalisme là mais disons que l'efficacité
ne que le produit d'un réalisme couple
est un impératif du réel qui impose au
maroc d'être efficace lorsqu'il fait
l'admiration des français ce sont les
masques qui sont disponibles en très
grand nombre au maroc un prix très
faibles en plus 7 centimes d'euros quand
on sait que nous on commence seulement à
en avoir à vendre dans les pharmacies et
qu'on a ce sera un peu moins de 5 euros
5 euros maximum ça fait une très très
grosse différence pourquoi comment tous
exactement comment avez vous fait pour
avoir tant de masse qui passait pas
compliqué c'est qu'enfin le l'état est
entré en contact avec un certain nombre
d'entreprises dans le domaine industriel
et dans le textile pour voir et ce qui
est une possibilité de créer une
synergie ont vu de mutualiser les
compétences et de produire tout
simplement un masque qui correspond à
des normes alors les normes iso mais
également des normes médicales
parce qu'on aurait été saisis pas de
marché de masques chirurgicaux mais de
masques de protection
c'est à dire qui protège les autres de
soi même quand on porte le masque mais
qui ne protège pas d'une contagion en
extérieur donc l'idée que tout le monde
doit porter le masque pour qu'on se
protéger mutuellement et donc très
rapidement on a reconverti réorienter un
potentiel industriel dans le textile
vers un textile plutôt médical et donc
il ya eu l'assistance des différents
médecins qui ont accompagné les
entreprises pour le faire donc
et là bon j'ai un exemple un exemplaire
du paquet avec dix masques vendu à 8
centimes d'euros
lorsque je vous montre comme ça tous les
français pourront voir donc c'est un
masque avec trois plis avec un élastique
donc qui couvre tout le visage rond qui
en gris en en bleu donc ça permet de
couvrir le nez l'intégralité du visage
alors il ne coûte pas cher ou une raison
très simple c'est que le maroc dès le
début des mesures entreprises par l'état
a mis en place un fonds spécial pour
gérer la pandémie du colis 19 un fonds
qui a reçu des dents de la part
d'entreprises prix des deux hommes
d'affaires
mais également deux entreprises
publiques et des institutions qui a
permis de rassembler très rapidement 34
milliards de dirhams faut à peu près 3
milliards d'euros et c'est grâce à ce
fonds que l'état subventionne des
masques donc en réalité le coût de
production des matchs ce qui est
supérieur aux à 70 ou 80 centimes
d'euros mais l'état fait en sorte que le
masque ne coûte pas cher et donc très
rapidement on a atteint un volume de
production de 7 millions de masques par
jour et bientôt on va passer à 8
millions de masques mais c'est tout
simplement une logique de 2 c'est un
choix politique c'est à dire on part de
l'idée que ce qui est intéressant dans
cette crise dans le cas du maroc c'est
qu'on redécouvre que quand une politique
des crêpes l'intendance fini par suivre
est en réalité dans la plupart des pays
qui n'arrivent pas à produire de masse
c'est parce qu'il n'ya pas une volonté
politique clairement affichée avec
fermeté dans quelle forme de la xive ou
une forme d' indécision une incapacité à
gérer des stocks mais je pense que tout
état notamment des états développés ont
largement les moyens de mobiliser des
ressources industrielles locales pour
conduire des masques donc l'exemple du
maroc est tout simplement quand on a
encore une verticalité du pouvoir qui
fait que le politique des crêpes et que
l'intendance fini par réagir c'est pour
répondre aux décrets jay politique ne
puis vous l'avez dit une industrie
textile qui sait l'utiliser au maroc qui
s'est délocalisée de pays comme la
france et qui s'est installé au maroc
tous ceux qui ont gardé la vérité si je
mens se souviennent que ceux qui vendent
des bus jean en france les fonds
fabriqués au maroc et mais ça a changé
depuis quelques temps parce qu'il faut
comprendre que le secteur du textile
marocain était mis à mal par la
concurrence notamment turc alors
chinoise mais entendu puis turcs et qui
fait que bon nombre d'entreprises
textiles marocaine on rencontre de
grandes difficultés certains ont connu
la faillite
d'autres ont réussi à se reconvertir au
niveau de certains créneaux relativement
intéressant il plus spécialisée et on
parle de ces entreprises là parce que
quand on parle de par exemple c'est là
il s'agit de soft est qu elle a
développé également des filières orienté
vers l'aspect technique médicale le
bâtiment etc
et donc c'est une stratégie de survie
qui ce qui se fera vers être payante
aujourd'hui donc mais dans le cas de la
france est effectivement il ya une
délocalisation importante du potentiel
industriel textile vers des pays
périphériques
que mais il ya quand même encore des
unités textile en france je veux dire on
n'est pas dans une délocalisation
intégral donc le maroc effectivement à
profiter des délocalisations étrangères
mais il a effectivement garder un noyau
dur capable de se reconvertir rapidement
il est capable j'ai une certaine
souplesse et une certaine polyvalence
mais il n' ya mal parce que depuis
quelques années on parle de d'un
éventuel retrait de l'accord de libre
échange qui vient du maroc et la turquie
alors ça n'a pas été fait mais le maroc
a activé une clause dérogatoire qui
permet de suspendre cet accord pendant
quelques mois et peut-être que ces
mesures-là ont été également salutaire
pour le maroc mais en réalité c'est tout
un paradigme qui pour voir c'est toute
la question des délocalisations des
accords de libre échange qui est
totalement belleterre donc on voit très
bien qu'en temps de crise ce qui est
pertinent c'est l'échelle nationale
c'est l'unique échelle qui est
suffisamment incarnés pour pouvoir
mobiliser toutes les ressources et venir
en aide à une population donnée mais
quand on est dans le discours
idéologique autour de la mondialisation
n'est dans un discours totalement
abstrait qui en réalité voile et cache
une guerre de tous contre tous
donc en réalité le maroc ce qui était
salutaire pour le maroc c'est son retard
en termes d'intégration économique à
l'échelle mondiale parce qu'on n'a pas
encore dilapidé tout notre potentiel
industriel qu'on s'en sort mieux que les
pays qui sont à l'avant garde de la
dilapidation de leur potentiel
industriel en rien les masques qui
empêche évidemment ralentissent la
propagation de la de la maladie
également le gel hydroalcoolique je
crois qu'il est fabriqué sur place au
maroc en partie avant déjà pour les
masses pour conclure il a été également
décidé par les autorités
les autorités marocaines d'imposer le
port obligatoire des masques donc
aujourd'hui à n'importe quel citoyen
marocain n'a pas le droit de sortir sans
le masquer
donc on a préparé au niveau de la
logistique la distribution des masses
qui a rencontré un certain nombre de
complications parce qu'au départ il y
avait une rareté une pénurie
on comprenait pas on nous dit en même
temps qu'il ya des millions de masques
mais on les trouve pas dans les points
de vente
mais petit à petit le retard a été
rattrapé aujourd'hui globalement porté
le marocain peut trouver un masque
d'autant plus qu'il est obligé de porter
au risque de payer une amende voire
d'aller en prison si jamais le réitère à
appeler reprise alors pour les
respiratoires il s'agit effectivement
d'un respect at war qui a été développé
par un certain nombre d'entreprises
entrer en synergie pour mutualiser les
compétences mais on est encore en phase
de prototype
donc on n'était pas aujourd'hui vous
parler du reste du respirateur
artificiel sont pour son maroquin dont
on a parlé oui mais il faut comprendre
qu'il ya différents types d'appareils
respiratoires et les types d'appareils
respiratoires complexe dans la
ventilation est invasive c'est-à-dire
par intubation il ne s'agit pas de cela
mais il s'agit d'un appareil
respiratoire mobile qui peut être
utilisé dans les ambulances et qui peut
aider uniquement les patients qui ont
des une détresse respiratoire mais avec
une cadence régulière
donc ces gens là ne réclame pas n'ont
pas fondamentalement besoin d'un
appareil complexe et donc ça permet de
libérer l'appareil complexes pour des
gens plus grave situation et d'utiliser
cela uniquement pour des cas
relativement relativement modérée mais
je le dis encore on est encore au niveau
de la phase de prototype donc on ne peut
pas encore le généraliser en or on est
en train de chercher à développer un
appareil un peu plus complexe mais
naturellement la temporalité de la
recherche mais pas celle de la crise
donc effectivement ne peut pas mobiliser
immédiatement
alors ça n'a pas empêché le maroc
d'acheter des appareils respiratoires à
l'étranger pour augmenter les capacités
des lits de réanimation pour des
équipements tels respiratoires mais en
attendant effectivement on redécouvre un
masque de l'économie marocaine qu'on a
occulté pendant des décennies c'est
qu'on est capable quand même de
mobiliser des gens talentueux des
ingénieurs des concepteurs
et différentes entreprises pour produire
un produit local alors fonds pour 100
marocain sait pas ce que ça veut dire si
les composants et les composants
électroniques vient de malaisie ou
d'ailleurs le montage se fera au maroc
la conception se fera au maroc bien
entendu et c'est le plus important dans
la démarche mais c'est un premier pas
peut-être vers une redécouverte du
principe de souveraineté économique
donc effectivement il ya un noyau dur de
secteurs stratégiques qui doivent
demeurer souverain technologiquement
économiquement et territorialement
notamment dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique la capacité à produire
des génériques et des médicaments au
niveau 2 les appareils sanitaires au
niveau de l'armement au niveau des
infrastructures
donc tout cela va devenir de plus en
plus à un impératif pour de plus en plus
d'états on dit également que le maroc on
aurait recours ou aux traitements
préconisés par le professeur raoul tu
dont on sait que jusqu'à présent les
essais cliniques n'ont pas été
suffisamment probants aux yeux des dés
que de la communauté scientifique ou au
maroc
c'est ce que l'on fait oui alors dès le
22 23 mars les stocks de knock in
disponible au maroc ont été
réquisitionnés par l'état et donc qu'il
s'agisse du plat cnil ou diva qu'il ya
la chloroquine nous dire hydroxy
chloroquine vous ne pouvez plus est
vaste et en pharmacie parce que l'état
eric a réquisitionné tous les stocks ont
vue de d'établir un protocole pour
soigner les gens qui arrivent au niveau
des centres de santé publique
donc effectivement fait une bithérapie
qui a été appliquée au maroc très tôt
qui a fait qu'ils intègrent hydroxy
chloroquine et l'azithromycine est un
antibiotique puis le pulmonaire et qui
comment dire qu'il met en avant le fait
que le maroc n'est pas tombé dans le
piège des luttes idéologiques et des
conflits d'intérêts que la france ait
connu c'est que quand on a le choix
entre deux choses on a le choix entre
l'un habite est rapide et peu proposée
par didier à eau ou bien rien j'ai la
face à rien face à la mort la bithérapie
s'avère prometteuse
donc après il faut comprendre qu'au
niveau de la recherche alors y est la
logique de protocoles de recherche qui
effectivement une temporalité de longue
durée avant d'aboutir à une autorisation
une législation
et puis à la réalité du médecin qui en
l'occurrence sur le terrain n'est pas un
chercheur et qui est confronté à une
réalité médias
des gens concret et qui doit chercher
dans l'arsenal qu'il possède les
molécules ancienne et connue qui peuvent
aider le patient à guérir et donc en
réalité au maroc on n'est pas allé
contre la recherche mais on a plutôt
favorisé ce qu'on appelle la médecine
observationnelles laser qui part du
terrain de la réalité pour soigner les
gens efficacement et les résultats sont
très intéressants au maroc c'est qu'on
voit que le maroc a adopté le protocole
vers le 22 mars
et dès le 9 avril on voit un décrochage
des morts cumulés quand on voit la cour
elle s'aplatit donc il ya de moins en
moins deux morts et on voit le cas de
guérison qui décolle littéralement temps
parce que pendant très longtemps durant
le mois de mars on avait un rapport
entre les défis cumulée et les guérisons
cumulé qui étaient très proches ont été
littéralement dans un bras de fer et
puis tout d'un coup il ya un décalage
extrêmement rapide et ça coïncide entre
autres avec l'introduction de
l'apithérapie tel que proposé par le
professeur didier raoult
parce que là encore en france on connais
très bien les conflits d'intérêts entre
butin levitin côté salomon de l'autre et
puis didier raoult de l'autre il ya des
gens qui veulent absolument un vaccin
pour pouvoir le vendre à à coups de
milliards à l'échelle planétaire par des
commandes publiques tandis que nani vert
tandis que la chloroquine qui ne coûte
pas cher et quand même embêtante pour
l'industrie pharmaceutique
d'autant plus que les résultats risquent
d'être surprenant quand on va obtenir
des résultats appuyé et on le voit très
bien la plupart des études qui ont été
commandées par l'état français vont tous
testés sorte la bithérapie de dire où
ils vont tester soit lille hydroxyque
dorking tout seul soit la chloroquine
tout seul mais jamais les deux donc le
lui il ya une guerre contre la
chloroquine et contre 7,8 et rapide donc
le maroc
là encore a fait preuve de réalisme il a
opté pour le choix le plus réaliste et
le plus efficace et heureusement on est
en train de voir une amélioration de la
situation au maroc après les chiffres et
plus dont quand on parle des cas
confirmés au maroc c'est conditionné par
la capacité de dépistage
qu'effectivement le maroc n'a pas les
moyens de mettre en place des dépistages
massive comme en allemagne lorsque au
total on a fait depuis le début de la
pandémie environ 28 est ce qui n'est
rien en réalité
mais par contre ce qui est tangible
c'est le cas de décès donc là on peut
pas tricher et le cas de guérison et là
par contre effectivement les résultats
sont très satisfaisants et très
encourageant mais il est évident que si
on élargit le
le dépistage on obtiendra beaucoup plus
de cas confirmés mais la majorité sont
symptomatiques
au maroc il y à un confinement alors
est-il strictes
est ce que la police est là pour le
faire respecter est ce qu'elles
rencontrent des difficultés pour le
faire respecter
le confinement été mis en place
graduellement donc on a commencé par
fermer les cafés les restaurants les
mêmes puis on a fermé les mosquées et là
ce qui est intéressant de voir c'est que
contrairement à ce que croyait beaucoup
d'observateurs occidentaux la fermeture
des mosquées a été globalement bien
accueilli ce qu'on a compris la logique
qui est derrière la question de la
préservation de la vie alors yeux une
minorité de gens dans la ville de phase
et de tanger qui est en forte manifestée
après le couvre-feu contre la fermeture
des mosquées
mais quand on a vu la réaction de la
quasi majorité des marocains sur des
réseaux ils ont été majoritairement
condamnée par tous les marocains
donc effectivement l'idée que les
mosquées soient fermés a été largement
accepté avec beaucoup de facilité
alors petit à petit on est allé vers un
confinement de puits non plus
généraliser
donc effectivement là des barrages de
police l'armée qui vient soutenir
également la police long terme en terme
logistique et une dérogation qui
réclamant aux citoyens pour une personne
par ménage en moyenne pour aller faire
les courses et pour aller travailler
hélas et c'est pas une déclaration sur
l'honneur mais c'est les agents
d'autorité qui doit signer la dérogation
pour pouvoir circuler
donc globalement de confinement est bien
respectée après bien entendu il faut
comprendre que dans les quartiers
populaires il ya un impératif de survie
et à des gens qui vivent au jour le jour
ce qui ne peut pas se permettre de
rester dans un confinement total et
radicale est donc naturellement ils
sortent travailler avec le port du
masque obligatoire
alors effectivement il ya des degrés de
respect du confinement qui vont changer
en fonction d'eux des classes
économiques concernés mais globalement
quelque part un relative laxisme est
tolérée par les autorités par rapport
aux cantines mans parce que peut-être je
suis pas médecin on pourra voir avec la
même salle mais peut-être que ça entre
dans une logique également de jubilation
de la pandémie parce qu un confinement
strict et radicale empêche la
constitution d'une immunité collective
par contre un confinement avec un degré
de liberté relative c'est à dire des
gens qui peuvent sortir ton des malades
puis des pistes et puis guérissa permet
petit à petit de juguler la pandémie
tout en accompagnant la mise en place
d'une immunité collective ans est une
hypothèse mais concrètement il ya une
adhésion globale par rapport aux mesures
entreprises par l'état parce que la
démarche n'a pas été une démarche
coercitives le dès le départ il ya eu
des campagnes avec des voitures de
police avec des microphones et les
haut-parleurs pour parler de manière
pédagogique aux gens pour leur expliquer
qu'on est là pour vous aider pour vous
servir et pas pour autant empêché de
sortir à pour vous punir et donc il ya
eu un visage bienveillant affichée par
les autorités
donc naturellement de l'autre côté il ya
une solidarité il ya une logique
paternaliste dans le schéma appliqué au
maroc est pas une logique coercitive sur
le plan culturel
comment expliquez vous alors le
comportement des marques un général
face à cette épidémie on sait que en
suède ou ne pratiquent pas le
confinement
ils s'embrassent peut se prennent plus
dans les bras en tout cas relativement
moins que les latins alors qu'en est il
des marocains que ce que vous avez pu
observer à ce sujet un fils de sufi en
effectivement une culture à cet acte ils
s'assoient sans même ceux touchés par
les effectivement a priori ces
problématiques de penser un vrai quand
il ment radical dans un champ culturel
tel que le nôtre mais en réalité déjà
commencé avant la dimension religieuse
que contrairement aux mouvements
évangélistes aux etats-unis mènent
eux-mêmes ailleurs dans le cas de
l'islam
il ya des textes religieux notamment des
hadiths qui préconise aux gens qui se
retrouvent dans des villages atteints de
la peste de ne pas quitter leur domicile
ou bien qui sont à l'extérieur du
village ou de la ville de ne pas entrer
dans des villages de la wilaya la teste
donc effectivement et un rapport à la
pandémie dans l'islam qui est un rapport
très pragmatique qui n'auraient pas
uniquement du métaphysique pure où dieu
ne sauvera quoi que je fasse
mais il ya une forme de réalisme
religieux qui est sa lutte à odieux me
punit quoi que je fasse aussi il ya
aussi l'idée de la punition
bing qui était très présent la peste
noire non plus dans le cas de l'islam
les cataclysmes naturels et les
pandémies naissante a vu que comme
définition quoi qu'ils peuvent être
perçus dans certains cas mais plutôt
comme des épreuves dieu éprouve la
capacité d'un peuple à réagir par
rapport à un cataclysme à faire preuve
d'humanité malgré la dureté des
conditions de la maladie de la bd de
l'épidémie où des cataclysmes donc
disant qu'il ya un fond religieux qui a
été favorable à une gestion intelligente
de la pandémie contrairement à d'autres
référentiel religieux alors le deuxième
élément il faut comprendre que dans le
cas du maroc
malgré la nucléarisation des ménages et
malgré la transition démographique que
l'on est en train d'être achevés
la rupture d'autorité que connaissent
tous les peuples qui achève la
transition démographique n'a pas été
très prononcée au maroc
je m'explique rapidement c'est-à-dire
que quand le taux d'alphabétisation
atteint la moitié de la population
on se retrouve avec la moitié de la
population qui sait lire et écrire
d'autres motifs qui ne sait pas lire et
en général c'est lévénez qui ne savent
pas lire et écrire c'est des enfants qui
savent lire et écrire et donc les
enfants accèdent un univers mental
beaucoup plus large que celui des
parents par l'écriture et par la lecture
et ont des coûts d'une rupture
d'autorité qui va se traduire également
par des ruptures d'autorités politiques
religieuses comme l'a connue l'europe et
d'autres régions du monde à l'entente le
cas du maroc comme la transition
démographique sait déployer très
rapidement après l'indépendance du maroc
tout s'est fait en accéléré donc au cas
des éléments de la transition n'a eu la
temporalité nécessaire pour se déployer
donc la rupture d'autorité et il existe
on le voit de manière objective mais
elle est encore atténuée par des liens
symboliques religieux culturels qui lie
les enfants par an donc dans le cas du
maroc les gens globalement sont encore
très attachés aux personnes âgées pas
uniquement leurs parents mais à la
personne âgée en tant que les personnes
âgées dans la rue on voit un skin d'inde
à moi mais c'est un monsieur âgé portent
des sacs de légumes et immédiatement des
jeunes qui viennent courir pour lui
proposer de l'aide
donc une forme de logique communautaire
qui persiste malgré la nucléarisation
des ménages et qui fait que très vite
les marocains ont compris que la
pandémie si l'ue de manière prioritaire
les personnes âgées qui sont plus
vulnérables les personnes à risque et
donc naturellement en respectant le
confinement je préserve mais mes aînés
je réserve mes parents mes grands
parents les grands parents des autres et
donc il est logique de
deux familles communautaire qui n'existe
pas qui n'existe plus dans la réalité de
manière objective mais gris qui existe
encore dans l'imaginaire et qui permet
de développer des mécanismes de
solidarité entre les dames et le
quartier entre la famille entre les
mails les différents ménages qui fait
qu'il ya des collectes dedans il ya des
distributions alimentaires qui se font
de manière généreuse à travers des dons
donc la dimension communautaire est
encore prégnante au maroc est encore
présente pour le meilleur et pour le
pire mais en l'occurrence le pen pour le
meilleur terminons cet entretien sur
l'économie vous êtes et que des
ministres
les travailleurs marocains sont
indemnisés par l'état à hauteur de 2000
dirhams je crois dans l'hypothèse où ils
ont été mis au chômage par le grenat
c'est bien cela fait donc il ya des
critères d'éligibilité
donc effectivement les entreprises qui
ont perdu la moitié de leur chiffre
d'affaires ils ont été obligés de
licencier des gens ont raison de la
baisse d'activité consécutive à la
pandémie effectivement ces gens là qui
sont déclarés qui sont dans le secteur
formel peuvent profiter d'une indemnité
de 2 mille dirhams qui représente les
trois quarts du salaire minimum donc
c'est pas grand chose mais ça permet à
ces journal de tenir le coup pendant
trois mois le temps de mettre en place
il peut éventuellement une politique de
relance
alors pour les gens de l'informel qui
effectivement souffrent davantage de la
crise économique parce qu'ils n'ont ni
retraite plus pas mais nulle ceux qui
travaillent au noir dès qu'ils
travaillent en noir effectivement n'en
parle pas des employeurs ils sont dans
l'illégalité la plus totale ils peuvent
pas profiter d'une indemnité une
embardée salle des gens qui travaillent
chez vous auprès de ces gens là
alors eux ils vont toucher une indemnité
inférieure à 2 mille dirhams
donc il va se situer entre 800 et 1200
dirhams en fonction de la taille du
ménage
donc c'est tout ce que peut faire le
maroc parce qu'on a rassemblé un fonds
de solidarité pour la lutte contre la
pandémie
mais on doit l'utiliser pour beaucoup
d'autres choses premièrement pour
équiper médicalement les hôpitaux en
termes d'appareils respiratoires
deuxièmement pour venir en aide aux
entreprises parce qu'il ya un report des
charges fiscales et un report des
crédits aussi bien pour les ménages que
pour les entreprises qui ont perdu 20
pour les ménages qui ont perdu leur
emploi et qui ne peuvent plus soutenir
les crédits pour le logement ou pour
autre chose et donc tout cela ça coûte
cher ne l'interdît pas gratuit donc ça
va se traduire par des pertes de
recettes fiscales par un déficit
budgétaire qui va s'aggraver donc tout
ce que peut faire le maroc dans
l'immédiat c'est
simon de garantir un minimum de
numéraires d'argent pour éviter un
désert monétaire au niveau des couches
inférieures et pour éviter une implosion
de la demande solvable
alors là c'est dans l'immédiat en étant
des ptic d'urgence globalement on peut
retrouver quasiment les mêmes dans
beaucoup de pays
mais la problématique se situe après au
niveau moyen et long terme
et là il ya un bras de fer au sein du
gouvernement marocain entre les tenants
d'une politique d'austérité qui ne veut
surtout pas mettre en danger les
équilibres macroéconomiques et ce qu'on
appelle la macroéconomie prudentielles
et donc ceux là préfèrent l'endettement
en vue de juguler la crise mais sans
toucher au déficit budgétaire et aux
autres agrégats de l'autre il ya les
tenants de la politique de relance qui
dit que les agrégats sont au service des
gens et pas l'inversé
c'est pas les gens qui doivent servir de
la gamme et melandri et donc il ya pas
de problème à creuser le déficit
budgétaire par de la dette intérieure en
vue d'injecter des liquidités dans
l'économie réelle et de relancer la
machine économique et entre d2 ce que
j'ai proposé personnellement ces deux
d'éviter les de la dérive des deux est
notamment déjà de se doter des moyens de
financement adéquat par une réforme du
statut de la banque centrale du maroc
dans le marais en partant de l'idée
qu'il ya deux dérives aujourd'hui dans
approche économique de la gestion du
comité 19 il ya les kurdes les
politiques d'assouplissement quantitatif
tels que déployés aux états unis déjà en
2008 et par la bce
à l'époque de la crise de 2008 est
encore aujourd'hui qui en réalité fait
de la banque centrale une imprimant une
imprimante géante pour le secteur
bancaire les marchés financiers donc ça
ne provoque pas d'inflation dans
l'économie réelle mais ça un flat les
marchés financiers qui ne veulent plus
strictement rien dit totalement
décorrélé de l'économie réelle
d'autres dérives c'est une banque
centrale soumises intégralement en
politique qui devait remettre imandt de
l'exécutif effectivement avec un risque
d'hyperinflation donc le milieu de juste
me dis que je propose c'est de créer un
canal de financement entre la banque
centrale et l'exécutif mais qui sera
géré par une interface indépendante des
deux qui devra évaluer la nature
productives ou non des besoins de
financements d'état d'agir si l'état a
besoin d'un financement pour des
stratégies de développement économique
ou pour mettre en place cet
investissement productif
il doit pouvoir se financer auprès de sa
banque centrale mais il est hors de
question que la banque centrale finance
les frais de fonctionnement et pour
aller plus loin
les gens peuvent consulter ma
proposition j'ai publiées sur des
réseaux où je propose de créer un
parlement économique entre les deux ils
se répandent de logos économique du
maroc dans le but étant de chapeauter
une grande stratégie de développement
économique qui va au delà d'une simple
politique de relance économique
car le mort peine encore à développer
une forme de dynamique endogène de
développement économique
peut-être que la crise la crise est
toujours une révélation c'est un
dévoilement côté que c'est une occasion
de faire un saut qualitatif de l'avant
et de renouer avec les paradigmes tels
que le protectionnisme éducateurs tels
que la repolitisation de la monnaie ou
partant de l'idée que la monnaie n'est
pas uniquement un objet technique mais
qu'il est avant tout un objet politique
elle est le fait du souverain et que de
fait on doit penser politiquement la
monnaie pas uniquement techniquement
donc toutes ces questions là se pose
aujourd'hui au maroc et je m'en réjouis
parce que je défends depuis des années
mais il a fallu malheureusement attendre
une pandémie pour que ces idées-là saint
pois sur le débat public
dernière question il nous reste une
minute rachid ffi 77 % des marocains
d'après les sondages seraient satisfaits
de la façon dont le gouvernement gère
l'épidémie
notre gouvernement francs seraient
vraies d'avoir un score pareil est ce
que c'est un sondage fiable veut
travailler ce qu'il reflète la réalité
alors oui et non parce que voir je vais
pas vous apprendre les limites du
sondage effectivement dès fois le faire
au doigt mouillé ça peut être pertinente
et fendage mais il ya des limites
inhérentes à ce sondage c'est déjà le
l'échantillon qui est marginale
résiduelles et qui ne peut pas reflété
naturellement l'état d'âme de la
majorité des marocains est donc la marge
d'erreur est extrêmement importante
et puis à la logique de tranches de
classe c'est à dire auprès de qui on
pose des questions il s'agit des couches
favorisées naturellement ils ont les
moyens de garder le même niveau de
confort même en temps de confinement
donc globalement ont pour eux ça fait
des vacances d'un mois mais pour les
couches les plus défavorisées
effectivement si on fait un sondage
uniquement au niveau de ces couches à on
trouvera des réponses radicalement
radicalement différente mais disons que
globalement au maroc la majorité des
marocains ne remet pas en cause
l'intention de l'état il part de l'idée
que l'état de bonnes intentions
harry peut se tromper peu mal communiqué
que mal mettre en pratique un certain
nombre de mesures mais que globalement
l'intention est bonne donc il s'agit pas
d' instrumentaliser politiquement la
crise donc et à ses dimensions
paternaliste qui est leur propre à la
monarchie marocaine qui effectivement
fait situe au delà des clivages
partisans des partis politiques et des
rivalités politiques et que la plupart
des décisions dont j'ai parlé depuis
tout à l'heure la création du fonds
ducobu 19 les directeurs d'entreprise a
été dictée par le roi donc les grandes
lignes ont décidé royalement qui par la
suite décliné au niveau de l'exécutif et
du législatif est donc en réalité on
n'est pas dans un état d'urgence au
maroc au plan constitutionnel puisque de
législatives fonctionne encore mais on
est dans une forme de jeux pour
apprendre carl schmitt qui définit la
souveraineté comme étant comment dire
comme étant celui qui décide de l'état
d'urgence franco maroc fait le roi qui
décident de l'état d'urgence alors il a
décidé constitutionnellement mais il
agit par delà les clivages partisans des
partis politiques et des rivalités
politiques d'où peut-être en partie
l'efficacité des différentes mesures
entreprises qui ne font pas discuter qui
sont déclinées au niveau opérationnel
rapidement efficacement
donc elle va de méfiance pour le dire
concrètement les pas de méfiance des
avis l'état
mais il ya des critiques par rapport aux
modalités d'application par rapport au
manque de transparence des fois et par
rapport à des cafouillages au niveau des
décisions qui font mal comprises mal
formulé mal interprétés merci raffiné
fléchi merci de nous avoir suivis
rendez-vous au prochain numéro
on explorera d'autres pays cités en
exemple notamment la suède qui n'a
toujours pas confiné
[Musique]
je